speaking of democrats and privilege
because one of those privileges is you
can say whatever you want
and the media doesn't really call you
out on it
well jen saki saki right sake not saki
saki more like sake like i'd like
another sake warm please
jen saki who is the white house uh white
house press secretary
she said the other day that basically
republicans are the one trying to defund
the police this is just pure gaslighting
this is pure nonsense this is we all
know it but they have no problem saying
it and she kind of smiles when she says
it so this is from a couple days ago and
then we got a great compilation for you
here's jen
saki the thought there basically that
somebody
some criminal who has been committing
crimes with limited interruption or
interference from police for the last
couple weeks or months
is going to stop this easy life of crime
if
they have a summer job well i think the
president believes that we shouldn't and
we shouldn't allow
access to guns to those criminals who
are
currently illegally biling them from
some dealers across the country and
part of his announcement is taking steps
to do exactly that but part of his
announcement
is also ensuring their specific guidance
to
communities across the country to ensure
that they have funding to get
more community police around the country
something that was supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that the other party was
for defunding the police i'll let others
say that but
man i mean sake you are disgusting
you're just a disgusting person because
if you believe that the destruction of
truth is something that you can do with
a smug smile on your face
and pretend that it's the republicans
that wanted to defund the police
you're just you're just awful like what
else how else are we supposed to analyze
these people
right like how else are we supposed to
analyze people
whose job it is to give us information
uh when they blatantly lie to us she
also before i show you this compilation
of democrats uh calling for defunding
the police not republicans
she said something to the effect of we
shouldn't allow guns to people who are
illegally getting them that's what she
said the president doesn't want
uh people who are illegally getting guns
to get guns
do you see the flaw in that statement
it's illegal already
but this is what they do with everything
we have laws that if you're a crazy
person
or a drug addict or a former felon or a
series of other things you can't get
guns and guess what you're not going to
believe this guys
people find ways around things and most
people who do mass shootings get the
guns
illegally okay we know that by the way
74 people
were shot in chicago last weekend six
fatally
did that make it to the white house
press conference did that make it to uh
cnn or wapo
or new york times or anything 74
people shot and by the way i'm willing
we can
i don't know that we'll even find the
numbers on this because they probably
don't know who did the shooting
uh or at least they probably haven't
arrested anybody or very few of the
people have been arrested but i'm gonna
guess out of the 74
shot all of the guns were probably
gotten illegally it's you it's not
nra members it's not people who go about
the legal systems
that then run around start shooting
people okay it's just not we know that
it isn't
there has been no evidence ever of a
mass shooting that was done by an nra
member
who got their gun legally okay so it's
just sort of double it's again it's the
double talk it's the double speak it's
this 1984 orwellian doublespeak
very similar to the ilhan omar story
that we just covered we the president
believes we shouldn't allow guns to
people who are illegally getting them
yes they're illegally getting them we
already don't allow it but people find a
way life finds away jeff goldblum
jurassic park well anyway then at the
end she says it's some might say
republicans are the ones
who wanted to defund the police okay
sake
take a look i am for defunding the
police
yes i support the g fund movement why
use the word defund why is the word
defront and it's like this is the word
that's coming from the street
many affluent suburb suburbs have
essentially already
begun pursuing a defunding of the police
in that
they fund schools not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department the minneapolis police
department is rotten
to the root defund the police does not
mean
abolish the police it means a dramatic
reduction
in the number of police in our poor
communities police are terrorizing black
and brown communities the evidence is
clear across the country those are
democrats
sake okay those are all democrats all
calling for defunding the police i
cannot find video
anywhere of any republicans calling for
defunding the police if you think
that voting against your bailouts has
something to do with defunding the
police i mean you're again
you're gaslighting you're intentionally
lying to the american people
those are all democrats calling we want
to take
money away from the police at the end
there i think that was rafael warnock
the uh the senator from georgia and he's
basically saying we don't want to defund
them like get rid of them we just want
to take their money away
yeah and then you know what happens then
they don't have the backing putting
aside that you
defunding the police you take money away
you take resources away
from them well then there's probably
going to be less of them there will be
less patrols and everything else
he says oh well then they're going to go
into you know certain places
uh and economically depressed areas and
blah blah you know
when they do studies time after time
those people generally want more police
they want
less crime okay that's not to defend
every police action
everyone knows that i don't think i need
to say that at this point but when you
defund the police
and then you don't get the cities
backing the police
more crime comes in you guys all the
know the numbers new york la
san francisco portland seattle
everywhere
that there is a progressive mayor there
is an increasing crime right now there
is an increase
in homicide there's an increase in
homelessness there's an increase in drug
use do you
not think that these things are
connected they might
sort of be connected in some
way so saki you're a liar
you're a liar and i don't know why it's
left for me to call you a liar i wish
somebody else
would call you out in the mainstream but
i know you guys got those people in your
pockets because of say it with me
everybody
democrat privilege